sings chief randy richardson breaking
down earlier today while speaking about
the murdered officer watch this
you have to understand this was not
supposed to happen
here
i've been i've been to too many of these
funerals
and i never thought ever that i would
have to be doing this
i do not want to be here today
i i would give anything not to
i did not know christmas morning
at four o'clock in the morning when i
said goodbye to him
and sent him off to his family that it
would be the last time
that i saw him
my department is hurting
we're struggling through this so please
be in mind when you see them
that is hard for them we're a family
we're not an agency we're a family
all right well joining me now
exclusively a stanislaus county sheriff
adam christensen
hi sheriff
hello lisa and thank you for having me
on the show uh sheriff our hearts just
break for you tonight and the community
i don't know how anyone can't watch that
without breaking down themselves
and with tears i just my heart goes out
to you and what you're feeling i know
randy richardson said that it was a
close-knit community
at the newman police department 12
people you can obviously see the love
and admiration that he had
for officer singh so i want to start out
with
his legacy in honoring him and what he
meant to you
and the newman police department can you
tell me about corporal saying
well i can tell you that the sheriff's
office is the lead investigative agency
and we
are fully supporting the newman police
department so
even though i'm the sheriff chief
richardson is really trying to keep his
team together and we're there to support
him
officer singh is the shining example
of what immigration in america should be
this is a young man who immigrated here
legally it was his dream to come to
america it was his dream to be a police
officer
and he worked hard to achieve that goal
and unfortunately he sacrificed his life
trying to defend and protect his
community newman is very small
it's almost like mayberry these critical
incidents don't occur
and for this law enforcement agency in
the history of its existence
this is their first line of duty death
and sir he leaves behind a wife and a
five-month-old child
can you tell us a little bit about his
family
he's got a wonderful family and i think
what chief richardson
shared with everyone your viewers in the
nation and even here
locally speaks to the character of
officer singh and how much he loved his
family
i think the photograph speaks volumes to
his devotion
not only to his family but his community
and sir just tell us a little bit more
about his dedication to the job i read
that he drove two and a half hours to
attend the police academy which he put
himself through
he took lessons to learn how to speak
english better
so he could move up the ladder can you
tell us a little bit more about that
dedication
he did and it's an amazing story he
didn't start with the newman police
department
he was a cadet in with the turlock
police department
he worked very hard he was a reserve
with the merced county sheriff's office
he pursued his dream and to get through
the academy
he was willing to make that commute
every day
to complete that training program making
him eligible to be a peace officer in
the state of california and yes
he knew that he was difficult to
understand because of his accent
and again he threw everything into
language classes
english is not his first language and
even i remember what he sounded like on
the radio and
we all kind of all chuckled about that
accent and how hard he worked to ensure
that his
language got better his english skills
got better because again he wanted
so badly to be a police officer and he
worked
diligently to achieve his goal and where
does this manhunt stand now
so we have identified a suspect although
we're not
naming that suspect primarily because we
have a very specific protocol
that we use to make positive
identifications and as you know
uh people use multiple aliases
oftentimes people
share similar or same names and we're
not going to make a mistake so
we're not ready to actually name the
suspect
but we have multiple teams utilizing
our federal law enforcement partners
state and local
partners we have multiple teams out
chasing down
multiple investigative leads we have a
hotline set up
and we are working
non-stop we're not sparing any expense
to hunt this suspect down and bring him
to justice are californians in danger
right now
no they're not yes this suspect is armed
and dangerous
but we believe he is on the run we have
no evidence whatsoever to believe he is
still a credible threat
although i suspect when law enforcement
moves in he might be
but we encourage the public there's
plenty of information out there
if you see him or you think you see this
suspect
do not approach him don't engage him
don't try to stop
him call 9-1-1 and let us come intercept
him
because we want to get him into custody
safely without anybody else being
injured or killed as a result
of this investigation or this incident
and do we know if the suspect has a
criminal background
not yet because again we're working on
that positive identification and so
without completing that protocol
we don't want to misidentify anybody so
we're going to make absolutely sure
that we have an identification and
really the best way to do that is
fingerprints
and we're not going to have that until
we get him in custody sir i want to ask
you about something you brought up at
the press conference earlier you made
the distinction between the fact that
corporal singh
came here legally he came here with a
sole purpose he wanted to be a police
officer he wanted to serve
this country he wanted to serve his
community and he drew the distinction
between the suspected killer
who came here broke the law and came
here illegally
why was it important you to draw that
distinction
because i want the nation to know i want
your viewers to know
that officer singh really should be the
focus of this investigation and his
sacrifice
but i also want everybody to know that
immigration is good for america
if done legally illegal immigration
doesn't serve our communities especially
criminals who victimize and exploit
our communities whether you hate
the president or love the president
border security goes hand in hand with
national security
the safety of our communities and public
safety we need to know who's in
our communities that shouldn't be we
should be
focusing on criminal activity without
political interference
and there is only one entity that can
fix immigration even though there are
laws on the books and we should stand by
the rule of law
and we should be enforcing those laws
congress is the only entity that can fix
this problem
and until they decide to depolarize
themselves
and focus on what's in the best interest
of the people
you can't establish a system of
immigration
that lacks bureaucracy hopefully
and allows people a path to become good
citizens and contribute to what makes
america great
officer singh he is the he is the
absolute
poster child for why
immigration works if done legally and
properly so should more be done at the
southern border to prevent
this illegal activity
well i think that there's at least from
what i know i
i think that there's a lot of great work
going on on our southern border
i think it's inexcusable that we
continue to attack the men and women
who are there either as members of
u.s customs the border patrol ice or any
of our other federal law enforcement
partners
stop demonizing and villainizing the men
and women who are there trying to
protect our communities
it's time to come together and fix the
problem and yes border security
needs to be a priority and it's not just
the immigration issue lisa
we have cartels that are trafficking
narcotics
weapons little girls we have a problem
with human trafficking
we need to secure our borders and we
need to give
the men and women who protect us our
federal law enforcement partners
the ability to do their job without
political interference
well and sir california has come under
fire for being a sanctuary state
has that hamstrung your ability to do
your job in any way
well certainly it has first of all and
as i told the president of the united
states when i sat next to him i don't
think we should be subjected to
political interference i understand
why the state legislature and
politicians have decided to create these
laws because they believe
that people need to be protected law
enforcement is here to protect people
but you can't provide sanctuary for
criminals that
all that does is silence the voices of
our victims and i certainly didn't sign
up to do that
remember that our partners with ice
great
great law enforcement partners they're
not in my county sweeping through
churches and schools and convenience
stores
they're only interested in the fugitives
and the criminals why are we providing
sanctuary for people who victimize and
exploit
the weak and the defenseless we should
not be doing that
and sir before i let you go is there any
place where viewers and people at
home can help the sting family
absolutely if you go to our facebook
page just search for the stanislaus
county sheriff's office
there's an official donation site
remember that there's also a lot of
fraudulent
creation of gofundme sites be very
careful of those
if it's not our official site which was
set up by the stanislaus
sworn deputies association and that is
on our facebook page
that is the only official site where
people can absolutely donate
and help this family understanding that
we're going to help this family there
are benefits available to them
and my office the sheriff's office and
the men and women of the stanislaus
county sheriff's office along with all
of our other local partners
you can absolutely be sure that we're
going to support officer saying and his
family
officer singh will never be forgotten
for his service and sacrifice and we
honor his legacy tonight sir thank you
so much for joining us our prayers are
with his family and your community thank
you lisa thank you sir